and the parck is kept in by the Panthers in KN
to Chu number 19 for Brandon monter shoots it
right on goal and a save by huler who stopped 37
of 38 in that win in Florida on December 21st and
that's one thing the Panthers do is they funnel
a lot of pucks and bodies to the front of the
net now the Panthers at back door feet to for
hay and that was wide now B David back in lost
it and Sam Reinhardt for the Panther dumps it in
gets it off the boards right in front and checked
there by Ley Justin Fulk on the ice had practiced
this morning so hopefully he's getting closer as
that is dumped in from Center Ice by Oliver Ean
Larson now Shen comes in one-on-one against that
glad now Shen turning to pass to S and a save
by stolar what a chance there forade set up
by the captain Chen and then nikoloff trying to
clear it away that's kept Alive by Ley and that
the BL is go to work in the offensive zone a
pass to Neighbors in front neighbors backhander
rebound they score Shen the captain breaks
that long gold drought in the Blues lead one
nothing it looks like he got the monkey off his
back as Braden Shen and Jake neighbors connect
here as Jake neighbors draws the penalty but
Braden Shen gets right towards the front of
the net right where you need to go get to the
inside you get rewarded and the captain forist
one Top Shot and now settled by Reinhardt he
has 13 Power Play Goals tops in the leak shot
right on goal hope for the save on barov now
the blues at the line Jordan kyou little tow
drag we saw him demonstrate out of the pregame
show of joy vitalic in front now a shot by cyu
and a save by stolar a couple goals in
the first being also had a goal called
back now Thomas in front turning pass to
Kyu a shot and a save by stolar and this
is kachu now for bhi and he wait shoots it
and off the goal post it hit aart of hoper
and hit the near Goal Post lose up by one
for Hagi came close off the arm and off the
[Music]
post and now Thomas again Corb Davis good
pass back to crew then CYO shoots it off
the crossbar what a rocket there and it
gives out the player an opportunity to
shoot short side and this was on the
power play he said when he was young
his coaches taught him to check with his
legs here's a shot and Holford got over
and made a great save on gadjovich now they
score and it's 1-1 as stenin ties [Music]
it get a great opportunity that Joel hord denies
but then they kind of skate past their coverage
and that leaves stenland wide open get another
look watch the blues jerseys they skate past
their coverage which is the front of the net and
they leave the Florida Panthers forward wide open
here for an opportunity who bats it out of the
air and the blue start back with Baron and now
for Hayes big crisscross to C right in a shot
rebound and Haze a chance piranha here using
his speed and then continuing to the front of the
net Mika laying down trips up a couple of players
then ends up blocking the shot PL the tire goalie
cam again catches Sammy C trying to get upstairs
again on stallers as there's a little bit there
kachuck trying to skate away from sunst under 10
to go in the period And kachuck dusts it off
and a drive right on goal rebound H made the
save on kach and the blues fire it down the
ice and that's going to do it the power play
will carry over into the second period what a
incredible save there by Joel huler at the end
of the period to keep this game all tied up
down towards in that a ccial protection play
of course Matthew kachuck initiating this and
then the shot coming here and Joel hord makes
the blocker save there and then the pad save on
Matthew kachuck to get to the NHL of a young age
you really have to have one attribute a great
skater or a great shot or you know great stick
if Defender and he has that great shot and uh I
goal there against that's too bad but uh yeah he
he's a really good player and I I think he's going
to have a ability to translate um quickly much of
a chance there on his 29th of the Season well
what's tough here for the blues is mat kachuck
has already taken the puck to the net a few
times on the power play he FS like he's going
to the net on this one gives just enough room
for Ryan Harting and lond Del get gets it back
to Center Ice 210 to go in the double Miner now
CPP and oh right off the goal post right there
by casber cin beating sters Kyu is there pucked
back to kyou in front handed back to Paro right
in SHO it and a save by stoar face off now won
by Hayes Panthers in front Bennett shot right on
goal and a save by hoper with the Chuck right
in his kitchen beats it back to scandel and a
one timer right on goal rebound to jao and a save
by stolar after kovich had a chance in the right
point prco is right there and now it's s on the
counter for Baron trying to walk around Veri
Panthers get it here comes kachak into the zone
drop P gets it back and he scores Matthew kachak
into the top corner and that makes it 3 to one
third here let's watch this play love them matth
K right here slows down waiting for that coverage
and then opens up for that one timer it's a very
smart play by Matthew kachuck to wait for that
help and then you have to respect Veri for the
shot you got to front the puck Matthew kachuck
opens up to the one-time and then beats hord puts
it on the boards and that comes around to linan
andon londel comes in trying to go wide on Paro
who cuts him off head back to forsing forsing
waiting shoots and he scores a scen ey shot to
the point by forsling and it's four to one Matthew
kachuk as we watch that puck get back to forsling
and then look at kachuck just pushes out here
suddenly creating some space and then gets his
stick down on the puck backhand deflection by
matth kachuk right there just enough of a tip
to change it great hand eye coordination by the
Panthers forward is that def Flex up over Joel
H and the face off won by forzen his dad was
pretty good at that wasn't he now Kyu stole
the puck he races in kyou have shot rebound to
Thomas and that CL got back to break it up and
Nick ly what a pass B davit he's got a breakaway
in the Clair and a backhander and a save and B DAV
looked around but no call and then is forced
to give it up and Florida on the counter with
Bennett he comes in shoots it right on goal and
a save by Hofer and no rebound four-minute power
play but couldn't get it in and the Panthers
operate again on the power play Matthew K Chuck
through his legs for the hatrick and that's
went just wide Panthers one for two tonight
and now it's barov Reinhardt shot right on goal
rebound kachuck out a whack at it now barkov to
a chock to Reinhardt and off his stick Cho that by
brunovich that goes back in stolar he was thinking
empty net there and a shot by Paro and stolar
got back he was thinking empty net goal there
Jamie another thing that's curious to me John is
I think Matthew could chuck Chu that wide maybe
on purpose and then he was looking for teammates
after he had an opportunity for that hatrick goal
so here's Matthew again and he'll get it this time
so the hatrick is sixth career hatrick first ever
against the Blues for Matthew kach have some
hats down on the ice from some Panthers fans
I believe this is where it starts here little
bit of a bounce then Matthew kachuck good Loft
on that and kachuck gets his third of the period
and that's going to do it as the Florida Panthers
win their eighth in a row they win tonight 5-1
behind the sixth career hatrick by Matthew kachu